to build a better place for you and I to
pray and after Allah's help we hope that
you guys can generally see donate so
that we thought of Sunnah can facilitate
for the people the community a place of
worship as you all may already know in
order to have a place of worship in West
London you need at least a couple
million that's why we have a target of 2
million so we urge the brothers and
sisters out there to donate generously
especially within the last 10 days of
Ramadan and remember we must invest a
lot of people that wish to invest in
this life but rarely know that the good
deeds of this world that we work for is
an investment for the afterlife the
prophet
isoever builds a house for Allah Allah
will build him a house in paradise and
you guys know those that have been to
see us the conditions that we're dealing
with no doubt alhamdulillah provided
much for the community with the very
small amount of space that we have but
since our community is growing it's come
to a point where we have to now expand
once again I ask you all to donate
generously